joe biden has simply turned the page we
have not our count from afghanistan
sadly it continues
americans held hostage behind enemy
lines day 107
ever think this would happen abandoning
americans behind enemy lines 107 days we
abandoned our fellow americans it's 120
days since joe promised to leave no
american behind he clearly lied to the
entire country sadly dishonesty is the
prevailing theme in this biden
administration joe promised you could
trust his word as a biden in reality
nothing could be further from the truth
now just take a look at his handling of
covert 19 on the campaign trail joe
promised to quote shut down the virus
not the country really but tonight more
americans we can report sadly have died
from covert 19 under joe biden's watch
in 2021 than under donald trump in 2020
and by the way another variant is on the
way now this despite joe inheriting not
one not two but three vaccines
therapeutics uh like monoclonal
monoclonal antibody treatments that he's
only mentioned one time he got that from
the trump administration
operation warp speed and now more than
350 000 americans have died from the
virus since joe's inauguration day now
according to biden himself circa 2020 he
based on his own definition should now
resign in a complete disgrace
this is what joe said
220 000 americans dead
if you hear nothing else i say tonight
hear this anyone is responsible for not
taking control
in fact not saying i'm i take no
responsibility initially
anyone who's responsible for that many
deaths should not remain as president of
the united states of america
well based on joe's statement he should
not remain the president of the united
states 350 000 dead americans on his
watch and by the way per usual he was
lying for political gain of course he
spent most of the campaign hiding in his
basement bunker in the candidate
protection program and just like his
racially charged lies about president
trump's travel ban oh get this he called
trump's initial travel ban 10 days after
the first identified case of coronavirus
in america it was hysteria xenophobia
fear-mongering he tweeted that banning
travel from any other part of the world
will not stop covert 19 and in response
to the former president's temporary ban
on certain african countries biden
released this statement he said trump
further diminished the u.s in the eyes
of the world by expanding his travel ban
this new african ban is designed to make
it harder for black and brown people to
immigrate to the united states it's a
disgrace we cannot let him succeed
well guess who just implemented a brand
new african band
joe biden that's right joe just banned
travel from multiple african countries
over fears surrounding what is the new
omicron variant so is joe biden lying
and playing the race card for political
gain or is he a hysterical xenophobic
fear-mongering racist disgrace of a
human being it's either one or the other
joe now tonight biden's dishonesty it's
hypocrisy it doesn't end there frankly
joe and fauci's face masquerade is is
hard to track first it was mass don't
work maybe it'll stop one little droplet
then it was one mask then two masks then
it was masks indoors but not outdoors
then it was vax or mask then it was vax
and mask now it's vax mask and booster
and probably boost the boosted booster
after first we will never ever mandate
no
now the mandates and breaking earlier a
federal judge blocked biden's vaccine
mandates in the first 10 states to sue
his administration that's another loss
in the courts for joe biden today more
mixed messages from biden he implored
all americans to wear mask indoors and
then he sauntered right back into the
west wing
mass free
can't make this up take a look i i
encourage everyone
to wear a mask when they're indoors in a
crowded circumstance like we are right
now
and unless you're eating or speaking at
a microphone
then later in the day during a meeting
with business leaders biden did have a
mask on but he wore it around his chin
that wouldn't be too helpful over the
holiday weekend biden was spotted inside
a crowded store in the prestigious
island of nantucket
shopping mask free despite you can see
right there there's joe and there's the
sign on the front door reading face
covering required so i wonder if joe is
going to be cited for breaking
nantucket's masked mandate or of course
he's a democrat the rules shouldn't
apply to him right
now tonight maybe we should cut joe a
break
after all he's really struggling with
his memory by all accounts joe biden is
a complete
cognitive mess there's no more ambiguity
there's no more debate the evidence is
in and today his struggles continue take
a look
as we enter the month of december this
month
compared to where we were last uh last
september last christmas
uh questions should america be worried
sir let me call on nancy bloomberg
let me call on alexis alexis
alex
we've got two alex alex reuters yes and
so the other alex doesn't have a heart
attack i want to call on him
is it that
mr president
two females
no i'm not an alex but i'd love to ask
one question
[Music]
okay let me ask the other alex
this is beyond embarrassing it is
humiliating for the entire country and
frankly it is also now extremely
dangerous as every one of our enemies
every hostile regime on this planet
earth they see this as well now
following that disastrous presser the
administration abruptly canceled biden
supply chain speech that was scheduled
for later in the day now it was more
than i guess joe could handle he
obviously needed nappy time now tonight
americans are struggling with so many
major crises all preventable and all
created by that guy joe biden now we
have a new coven 19 variant is likely on
the way according to top health
officials though in south africa those
infected with the omicron variant at
this time i hope it stays this way
they're reporting that they are
experiencing mild symptoms but we will
see what happens remember this is the
latest of many variants thus far the
lambda variant the mu or mu variant the
r.1 variant as always i encourage all of
you to take this virus seriously consult
with your doctor do your own research
some research you agree with and
disagree with and while we don't know
exactly how the omicron variant will
play out in the u.s we do know that joe
biden is not fit to serve he will only
make things worse not better and the
american people they are speaking out
loudly they agree according to a new
rasmussen poll donald trump has a
massive double-digit lead over joe biden
in a 2024 head-to-head matchup
thankfully the 2022 midterm elections
are just around the corner because the
democrats one-party rule in d.c is
literally a wrecking ball to this
country no other way to describe it take
a look
one party rule what has one year of
democrat control of washington given us
shortages inflation crime chaos division
and failure
one party one year
one party one year minority leader
mccarthy will join us with more on that
ad in a moment